[Música]
la carrera está a punto de iniciar el
primer impulso es salir a ganar mucho
antes de dar el primer paso comienzas a
respirar a liberar y estás listo para
reaccionar se acelera el ritmo de la
frecuencia cardíaca tus pensamientos
saben entrega a decisión años
preparándote para este momento sudando
esforzándote entregando te llevando tus
capacidades al límite desafiando el
momento se acerca la recta final es
momento de demostrar que la disciplina
la perseverancia la técnica y el coraje
son la clave para llegar al éxito
momentos de mucha intensidad
esto y más es lo que se vive y se siente
en una competencia deportiva sea cual
sea el deporte la emoción que emana de
tu cuerpo como vibra la adrenalina que
recorre cada segmento los nervios antes
de pisar la línea de salida todo esto se
vuelve un cúmulo de sensaciones que
genera cierto tipo de adicción
yo lo viví muchas ocasiones como
deportista y ahora como entrenador quien
ha practicado algún deporte o alguna
disciplina sabe a qué me refiero y si no
te invito a que lo experimentes
ese momento en el que los nervios te
cuestionan que sucederá al final del
evento cuál será el resultado si tu
preparación fue la adecuada como
terminarás si tus rivales son fuertes o
no en fin una serie de preguntas que
giran en tu mente pero que la
respiración profunda y la experiencia te
ayudan a controlar a canalizar la
energía de manera favor la favorable
para buscar tu objetivo ganar una
competencia por ejemplo
esta sensación de una competencia la
vivo día a día por la mañana al iniciar
mis actividades dando mi primer clase
después correr para llegar a la
administración pública por la tarde
vivir el entrenamiento deportivo llevar
mis capacidades al límite y por la noche
estar en los medios de comunicación y
siempre viene esa pregunta cómo le haces
mi respuesta es sencilla lo aprendí en
el deporte hablar del deporte es
maravilloso desde cualquier ámbito cual
sea la práctica salud recreación
socialización rendimiento cualquiera te
lleva a disfrutar de múltiples
sensaciones y grandes beneficios por
ejemplo a nivel psíquico disminuye el
estrés aporta bienestar a través de la
secreción de endorfinas te ayuda a
mejorar tu sueño a nivel socio afectivo
mejora tu autoestima te enseña el
cumplimiento de normas valores actitudes
te ayuda a relacionarte e integrarte en
grupos sociales y a nivel físico no se
diga desarrolla tus capacidades físicas
al límite mejora tu rendimiento son
muchas las bondades del deporte en el
ser humano a tal grado que yo lo
considero un factor importante en el
desarrollo integral ya que te permite
reconocer habilidades talentos
desarrollarlos y potenciarlos
te ayuda a mejorar tu nivel de manera
progresiva
aún recuerdo ese momento en el que tuve
el primer acercamiento con el deporte
desde muy pequeño yo siempre fue un niño
muy inquieto con mucha energía y que
generaba un dolor de cabeza para mis
padres quienes acertadamente encontraron
la solución para todo este caos en las
actividades deportivas y recreativas
me encuentro con el deporte de manera
formal no distancia mucho al que han
tenido otras personas al ser una persona
inquieta con todas las cualidades quizás
en ese momento destacadas puede ser
detectado por un profesor de educación
física a quien le agradezco tanto porque
me llevo a conocer la disciplina que se
convertiría en mi escuela de vida el
atletismo al que le debo tanto los
momentos más significativos y el
aprendizaje de grandes lecciones de vida
es muy marcado el momento en el que a
los 11 años pude pisar por primera vez
una pista atlética
a esa edad fue como entrar a un centro
de diversiones ver atletas corriendo
desafiando las leyes de la gravedad
ejecutando técnicas y lo más importante
identificar la sensación de que ese era
mi lugar al que quería pertenecer al
lugar a donde quería yo llegar y
desarrollar todas mis facultades
desarrollarme y aprender mucho nunca me
imaginé que aquello a lo que yo le
llamaba carreritas afuera de mi casa y
en las que no perdía la oportunidad de
retar a mis vecinos ya mi primo se
convertiría en todo un pasatiempo una
diversión un compromiso en el que había
toda una preparación de manera
sistematizada para enfrentar las
competencias y que no sólo era correr y
ya como muchos creen
sino que existen una variedad de pruebas
en las que puedes desafiar sus
capacidades físicas e intelectuales
fue asombroso conocer todo eso a tal
grado que se llegó a convertir en mi
verdadera pasión en un estilo de vida
que como deportista y entrenador me ha
llevado a vivir grandes experiencias
como viajar conocer grandes personas
lugares traspasar fronteras gracias al
deporte pude viajar por primera vez en
un avión incluso llegué a convertirme en
embajador de una marca de bebida
hidratante
una de las cosas más valiosas es que
gracias a este deporte pude llevar al
límite mis capacidades reconocer mis
alcances pero también mis limitaciones
pude conocer gente valiosa que me ha
acompañado a lo largo de todo este
trayecto con quienes he compartido
momentos experiencias aprendizajes en
este trayecto en constante evolución
el atletismo me enseñó las caídas la
frustración el coraje y la determinación
de levantarte y salir adelante en cada
paso me enseñó a ganar pero también a
perder y aprender de todo ello
entrenador fue muy preciso al
compartirnos la idea de que debemos
buscar ser triunfadores en la vida y no
de un solo momento mensaje con el cual
me pude identificar con el cual pude
encontrar una misión que busco compartir
en todo momento con mis alumnos y
deportistas este deporte me enseñó a
reconocerme a mí mismo a poder
desarrollar un carácter una personalidad
basada en los valores en la disciplina
el trabajo la perseverancia la
dedicación la fuerza de voluntad el
respeto la responsabilidad y mucho más
todo este acervo de aprendizaje atlético
adquirido a lo largo de los años 20 para
ser exactos me llevó a tomar decisiones
a trasladar la aplicación de todos esos
valores del deporte del entrenamiento a
otro contexto a continuar construyendo
una historia que para mí valiera la pena
compartir a lo largo de mi vida en la
que yo pudiera disfrutar de todo ese
trayecto de sentirme pleno realizado
libre de hacer lo que me gusta y lo que
me apasiona
recuerdo en algún momento en la
universidad que hubo una pregunta que me
despertó mucha inquietud
quiere ser especialista en una
determinada área del conocimiento o
englobar y abarcar las que se puedan tu
cerebro lo puede hacer una pregunta
interesante que me hizo pensar mucho me
quito el sueño y con ello llegué a darme
cuenta que vivimos en un mundo en
constante movimiento y que el ritmo de
toda esta revolución nos lleva a ejercer
cambios a innovar a ser diferentes a
compartir experiencias variadas a buscar
consolidar sinergias interesantes con la
gente que nos rodea bien dicen que el
trabajo en equipo multiplica los
resultados
bajo esa idea
tomé la decisión
de controlar el timón de este barco que
es mi vida y comencé a incursionar en
otras áreas a complementar mi formación
personal y profesional este viaje me
llevó a desarrollar un perfil
multidisciplinario lleno de experiencias
que me llevaron a abrir un sinfín de
oportunidades en ámbitos como la
contaduría la administración me permitió
participar en proyectos de marketing
encontrar una vocación en la educación
en la cultura física que es tan amplia y
maravillosa me pude identificar con la
pasión por la música vibrar con las
notas musicales identificar una voz que
me abrió las puertas en los medios de
comunicación
el cambio y el desarrollo nos incita a
ser multidisciplinarios un perfil de
este tipo quizás nos lleve a pensar en
la capacidad de desempeñar tareas
variadas en temas diversos pero en
realidad yo lo veo como la capacidad de
adaptación al cambio en algún momento
viví el proceso de selección en un
proyecto televisivo y en uno de los
filtros la pregunta fue suponiendo que
estás en un contexto totalmente
desconocido en el que no sabes a qué te
vas a enfrentar y el objetivo es
sobrevivir nosotros te damos la
oportunidad de que te lleves tres cosas
cuáles serían
mi respuesta fue inmediata no me
llevaría nada
pudiera elegir mil cosas pero en
realidad no sé si las podría utilizar en
el contexto al que voy es un reto de
sobrevivencia lo importante e
interesante es que tú estés ahí y a
partir de tus capacidades y habilidades
te adaptes al contexto enfrente en la
competencia y logres el objetivo
sin duda se volvió una respuesta que
salió del denominador de los demás
participantes inmediatamente hubo
reacciones y ahí entendí la clave de
buscar hacer cosas diferentes a partir
del ser hacer y compartir y esto me lo
enseñó el deporte
para alcanzar a hacer ese personaje
multidisciplinario se tienen que ampliar
los conocimientos las habilidades y las
competencias y hacerlo todo con
responsabilidad otro valor importante
que me dejó el deporte y el momento en
el que dimensiones la magnitud del
significado de este valor fue cuando me
encontraba en una clase de educación
física en secundaria y uno de mis
alumnos me dijo profesor quiero ser como
usted en donde estudió yo quiero estar
en la misma escuela y aprender todo lo
que usted sabe hacer
inmediatamente interrumpí lo que me
ocupaba quise responder se me acabaron
las palabras no supe qué decir y me di
cuenta de la importante responsabilidad
de influir en la formación de otras
personas tú no sabes en qué momento tus
acciones pueden ser la referencia
positiva o negativa de otras personas en
qué momento te puedas convertir en la
inspiración de otros recientemente me
encontré otro ex alumno en un espacio
deportivo ejercitándose me dio gusto
verlo y lo primero que hice fue
felicitarlo por haber aprobado su examen
de ingreso a un centro educativo naval y
su respuesta fue gracias lo logré y
gracias a toda su ayuda puede pasar el
filtro de pruebas físicas
momentos de reflexión y de mucha
satisfacción
toda esta responsabilidad que exige
seguir capacitando te profesionalizando
te y a desarrollarse de manera integral
buscar la manera de actuar de forma
organizada objetiva sobre todo de manera
disciplinada para ejercer ese papel
multifacético que tanto se disfruta
el día que haces valer toda esa
formación integral cumples propósitos de
vida te das cuenta de tantas cosas
identificas emociones todos esos cambios
y procesos químicos en tu cuerpo que
viviste durante una competencia esa que
te compartí al inicio de esta charla
recuerdas
y ahora la disfrutas todavía más porque
estás en la competencia de la vida
porque ahora tomas decisiones que
impactan en el rumbo que tu vida puede
tomar
y sabes que cuando te encuentras en una
situación crucial
la respiración profunda
esa que utilizaste para controlar los
nervios antes de escuchar el disparo de
salida te acuerdas
hoy te ayuda a mantener el control
buscar alternativas y salir avante tener
la plena confianza de saber que puedes
seguir adelante en la consecución de tus
objetivos
desarrollar ese plan y emprender
acciones que marquen la diferencia
encontrar toda esa motivación eso que
siempre está en tu cabeza y que hace
levantarte cuidarte concentrarte como lo
hacías en los entrenamientos
ahora lo haces para ir al trabajo para
ir a la escuela para hacer la actividad
que tanto deseas enfrentar los cambios
tomar esos riesgos para poder lograr
nuevos resultados nuevos aprendizajes
desafiar todas tus capacidades y
llevarlas al límite darte cuenta hasta
donde eres capaz de llegar
atrévete a tomar esos retos abrir nuevas
oportunidades algo que me ha quedado
claro en todo este trayecto es que un
comentario un momento una persona un
error una calificación no te definen ni
determinan hasta dónde puede llegar
es tu actitud y tus decisiones las que
prevalecen para poder determinar quién
eres y hacia dónde vas atrévete a vencer
todo ese miedo a romper el límite la
vida está llena de oportunidades para
hacer mejores deportistas mejores
profesionistas pero sobre todo mejores
seres humanos no te quedes ahí sentado
esperando tu momento mueve los elementos
que tienes a tu alcance y crea esa
oportunidad que tanto anhelas en tus
manos está la decisión de tomar esa
oportunidad y apoderarse de todo el
éxito que ésta pueda generar te y
transformar tu vida
finalmente te invito a que busques esa
inspiración esa clave que te mantiene en
el camino para saber ser saber hacer
pero sobre todo lo más importante saber
compartir
concéntrate y recuerda
tu carrera está a punto de iniciar la
meta la define esto el objetivo es claro
llegar a la meta la meta es el éxito y
el éxito lo encuentras en cada paso
gracias
[Música]